[Music]
hey what is up guys mkbhd here
all right
we finally have it it's finally here
after many leaks and much anticipation
the iphone 11 is officially official so
there's going to be a separate video on
the also new iphone 11 pro uh it's
either about to be up or already up
depending on when you watch this but
it'll be the first link below that like
button i'll make sure of that but either
way this is the new iphone 11 the
successor to the iphone 10r
and this is your first look at it so as
you can already tell it's going to look
and feel
very familiar with uh just a few key
changes so design wise i was kind of
hoping for maybe a slightly different
design maybe squared up a bit or maybe a
slightly smaller notch or something a
bit more modern feeling but that's not
really what's happening here it's almost
the exact same design as the iphone 10r
same curves same buttons same mute
switch same notch
same lightning port same speaker setup
same pretty much everything the display
is still an lcd it's a 6.1 inch liquid
retina display still the same roughly
720p resolution
no bump there but what's different is
the apple logo on the back is now moved
down a bit to the exact center of the
phone and it no longer has the iphone
text just the logo and really the main
new feature on the outside as you can
tell is the camera and that's really the
main theme here that's the main focus if
you will of the iphone 11 it's the
camera dual cameras now one 12 megapixel
standard and one 12 megapixel ultra wide
and this camera bump it's kind of
interesting so the phone is of course as
you can see still glossy all the way
across the whole back like last year but
then just this rounded square that's a
little bit taller than the rest has this
sort of frosted matte glass with a
camera circle with the metal rings
inside it and they sort of raise at two
different levels so it's the square
camera bump and then the camera bumps
inside of the camera bump and you can
feel that it's definitely unique and
it's easily the most polarizing part of
the whole phone some people like it some
people hate it to me i've been staring
at it for so long shooting this video
that it just kind of looks like any
other iphone at this point it's fine
but actually it's basically the opposite
of the iphone 11 pro which has a frosted
glass back on the whole phone but then a
glossy glass camera square so fun fact
but anyway like i said 11 pro video is
separate i'm just pumped to have an
ultrawide camera on the back of the
iphone now and both cameras are capable
of all the same stuff both with 4k 60fps
video hdr some really intense color
matching is being done between them the
whole deal and then the camera app is
also updated a bit for the iphone 11 and
11 pro and i'll talk about this more in
the 11 pro video because i have some
stronger feelings about it uh but
generally it's pretty familiar but there
are some tweaks so when you first open
the camera app the app kind of hints at
ultrawide by showing you this faded out
extra wide shot that's wider than your
current frame but not in your shot and
then you can hit that one x button at
the bottom to punch out to ultra wide
and then you get everything in there
that is your glorious iphone
super wide camera
this is going to be great for again
people who are shooting a lot of iphone
video those vloggers it's 4k the iphone
is still ip68 water resistant so it can
get kind of wet like a gopro if you want
to
um
i don't know i'm just glad they finally
got on this ultra wide train so that's
good the selfie camera on the front is
also not upgraded it's now a 12
megapixel camera and it's a tiny bit
wider
and you can access this extra little bit
of wideness by hitting the little
expansion button in the middle or
by default it'll actually just go wider
when you flip the phone sideways because
you're probably taking a group shot but
honestly it really is just a tiny bit
wider and also now slow motion video is
now supported by the front-facing camera
and for whatever reason they decided to
name this and they're naming it slow
fees
slow motion selfies uh
that's probably the first and last time
i'll ever say that word out loud but
there's also a new night mode and this
is something we've been looking forward
to ever since pixel's night sight took
direct jabs at the iphone on stage and
you know huawei's night mode has gotten
extremely good and others have started
making their own night modes we've been
sort of curious what apple's cooking up
for their night mode for the iphone so
we have iphone 11 we get this night mode
but as you may notice it's not in the
default modes down here at the bottom it
actually only activates when it's dark
enough so i could kind of trick it by
covering up the lens making it dark and
then a new night mode indicator pops up
in the top left and then you can decide
to adjust it or turn it off from there
but you can't turn it on anytime you
want
either way this is definitely something
i will be testing for the full review
along with all this other camera stuff
very curious to see how it performs and
if it's as good as what they should on
stage and as good as the others but it's
here there's a night mode
and then the other new thing is of
course your new specs the internals a
new a13 bionic chip which they say is
the most powerful cpu and gpu in any
phone and honestly i tend to believe
them at this point on a seven nanometer
architecture apple has been making
incredible silicon in their phones for
years so i'm expecting great performance
and not only is it more powerful but
they also claim the battery will last
one hour longer than the iphone 10r
which was already really good and then
there's also something they didn't even
mention on stage which is there's a new
dedicated u1 chip which will help with
spatial positioning relative to other u1
enabled phones and my favorite demo or
use case of this is two iphone 11s near
each other you can airdrop files back
and forth by like
beaming them at the other phone it uses
an ultra wide band signal which as far
as i can tell is the first i've seen
this used in this way in a smartphone
and yeah you can you can just
send memes or whatever you want just
beam airdrops directly at other people
it'll show up first in the share sheet
when you point it at the other person's
phone which is pretty cool and some
other minor stuff face id on this phone
they say is now up to 30 faster uh and
will supposedly work at more angles but
i'm not exactly sure how many new angles
if it's like drastically better we all
know how hard it is to unlock an iphone
that's sitting on a table so i'm hoping
this makes that a bit easier and then
the portrait mode in the camera also
will now work on people and pets and
objects so if you remember the iphone
10r would only let you try portrait mode
when it detected a human face so that's
a new feature for iphone 11 you can take
portrait mode on anything and that's uh
that's about it for new features for
iphone 11 listen it's a subtle update no
way around that it's very incremental is
the word we like to use
especially when the design is super
super similar
but
honestly for apple this is probably not
a bad thing see the iphone 10r was by
far the most popular phone apple sold in
their lineup last year it sold more than
the iphone 10s and 10s max thanks to the
lower price and so this year they're
actually lowering the price it's down to
a 699 starting price for the iphone 11
and that's probably going to be the case
here again this year it's probably going
to be their most popular iphone uh
there's six new colors for people to
pick from so you can go nuts again with
yellow or purple or green or whatever
suits you or grab a skin whatever you
got to do but uh yeah they're gonna feel
very familiar to people who have used
any iphone the 10r or any 10s or
anything from the past few years really
and that's probably what apples wanted
my only disappointment really i think is
the display i was kind of hoping they
would bump up the resolution because the
lower resolution of the 10r was kind of
my only big disappointment with it i
mean it was kind of everyone's
disappointment
but then again you know dropping the
price to 6.99 apple's not a company that
drops the price on a new item
very often so i guess i can't really be
mad but you already know i got to put it
through my testing i got to take my
sample photos take my videos use the
phone see how that battery life is and
all that will reveal if it's actually
worth the money but yeah that's
basically it that is what's new with
iphone 11. um feel free to share this
video with others who you think are also
interested in the iphone 11 and of
course stay tuned for the iphone 11 pro
video link below and today there was
also a new apple watch series 5 a
smaller update but with an always-on
display now and the same battery life
which is cool and there's a new baseline
10.2 inch ipad with pencil support and
smart connector pins and a pretty great
low price there's going to be a new
podcast episode of the waveform podcast
detailing all of this stuff so stay
tuned for that if you want a full
breakdown of the event um but yeah
definitely get subscribed to see the
review videos when they come out if you
haven't already so this has been your
first look at the iphone 11 thank you
very much for watching and i'll catch
you guys in the next one
peace
[Music]